[Musique]
j'ai été informé il ya à peu près un an
par par d'état qu'il y avait une
réflexion sur suite à la volonté du
président de la république de construire
quinze mille places de prison la cible
et je dirais la réflexion de l'état
était sur ma commune je peux vous dire
qu'aussi et je peux comprendre l'émoi de
la population mais quand on me l'a dit
je suis assez un peu et beaucoup scotché
mais non j'ai demandé mais pourquoi la
nuit en ville à l'époque on m'a indiqué
que magnanville était proche de
l'autoroute ban est en vie n'était pas
loin de versailles etc c'est une maison
d'arrêt donc les gens n'étaient pas
condamné c'était avant jugement et donc
il est en fait ce maire
il ya il ya quand même des éléments qui
ont aucune réponse que j'ai posée quand
j'ai eu une entrevue avec garde des
sceaux c'est les questions de mobilité
c'est les questions de sécurité sur les
questions environnementales
c'est des questions aussi d'évaluation
foncière des biens même si on dit dans
les biens l'évaluation des biens va pas
baisser mais les gens ils se disent la
pose ces questions là donc moi j'ai posé
ces questions là pour l'instant je n'ai
pas de réponses à ces questions là donc
c'est vrai qu'on est à la construction
d'un projet pour l'état mais dans le
même temps je le dis sincèrement ces
violences danon ce qui a été fait à la
population et qui est inacceptable
pas de garde des sceaux il va y m'a dit
que c'était décision d'êta qu'en gros il
m'a fait comprendre c'est bien que qu'on
soit informé mais bon les décisions
d'état il n'y a pas besoin de
consultation de la population et
consultation des élus
le rôle du collectif qui a été bien en
place parce qu'il est là aussi bas pour
pour apporter et proposer des solutions
aux gens bien entendu des solutions
d'action parce qu' il dise concrètement
ils sont contre la construction de cette
maison d'arrêt et ils vont tout faire
pour que le projet soit abandonné